ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show happy memorial day and
thanks everyone uh for your service
um what does memorial day mean to you
so much so much correct
now the olympics are
happening in tokyo what we think
i'm we i'm wheezing when i go to breathe
i don't know what that is but it's not
i it would make a lot of sense if i got
this right at the end
like after i've been vaccinated a month
after this is all over i just dropped
dead
like i made it through the entire thing
i went on the road
i was not taking it seriously i barely
wore a mask
finally get vaccinated memorial day
everything opens back up
i dropped out of it when it's not even a
news story
it's not even in the top five news
stories i just
pass away from covid
tokyo is learning that the only force
stronger than a pandemic
is the olympics
olympic organizers say games must go on
tokyo is getting hit
in japan the population has turned
against the olympics
one poll found a whopping 83 percent
opposes staging the games this summer
83 percent nevertheless
japanese prime minister yoshida suga
tokyo organizing community president
seiko hashimoto
and international olympic committee
president thomas bach
insist that the show must go on
he goes ioc the olympics committee their
spokesman mark adams went as far to say
we listen
but won't be guided by public opinion
that should be
the quote of of of everyone in power
anywhere we listen
but we won't be guided by public opinion
we're listening
but that's where it ends it ends at
listening
um so they have a state of emergency
happening right now because of coven and
hospital capacity is a problem
and they're in some other some type of
lockdown i believe and they're gonna do
the olympics um there's also
militarized security measures including
surface-to-air missiles
ratcheted to the roof of an apartment
complex defend of terrorist attacks
that's nice
they want you know olympics brings in a
lot of money
for i they had they were thinking about
la for the olympics in a few years and
everybody was like
no because they had to move the homeless
people for the academy awards and they
got upset they go well
can you only imagine what will happen
to the homeless in la if you have the
olympics
i say let them compete but no one has
thought of that compromise um
first of all and i'm wearing glasses now
because the lights we're in the middle
of getting a new studio here and the
light the lights are so
oppressive that they hurt my eyes and
i'm getting ready for the miami bitcoin
conference
uh don't even want to tell you who we
have it is so
um monumental and it's going to be wild
uh
guests we have several guests
several of them are trying to pull out
as we speak because we're handing others
and we don't know we're it's a real
behind the scenes
you know musical chairs up there to see
who's gonna sit with us
at the main stage uh when saturday
saturday at 4 15. saturday 4 15 the main
stage of the convention
tim dillon show podcast with
guests um
[Music]
so this is interesting first of all the
way i have
felt about when is the last time you
watched the olympics
oh man probably phelps right do adults
still watch the olympics does anyone
care
can we stop pretending that this matters
in anyone's life this is not
diplomacy anymore like this idea that
it's like it's sportsmanship
and it's diplomatic and it helps
international relations to have people
it it does it
is do the palestinians have a delegation
in the israeli and that's going to
matter
if israel and palestine play volleyball
is that really gonna matter
i understand at a time potentially but
right now i think things are at the
point now where
no one cares anymore about this
adults do not watch from what i mean
children watch it my dad and me used to
watch it
we used to watch uh the olympics because
people had fun names like peek-a-boo
street
that skiing or or there was a speed
skater named hey chavo
we liked that um and you'd watch it with
you you know i'd say they were my dad
and we'd eat haagen-dazs ice cream
and and uh and fast food and we'd watch
the olympics
um and then you know they would have all
these inspiring stories
of people but the stories now have
gotten so hellish
they've gotten so disturbing
that and first of all have you ever met
anyone that
like got close to the olympics or
qualified for the olympics
and went and didn't place like these are
the most
destroyed people you'll ever meet like
my friend's sister
like went to the olympics in volleyball
like nothing happened
and she just i mean the woman is a wreck
she's just like a tall beanstalk of a
woman
and we'll we'll tell people like she
went to the olympics but
nothing nothing came out of it so it's
it's it's only nice if you're winning a
medal truly
otherwise and
it used to be like oh you know
she was the youngest of six kids and she
used to ski
going down the stairs like they were
like heartwarming stories
about the olympians like she used to put
on you know
she used to take her brothers uh you
know uh
skateboard and pretend that they were it
was a snowboard and she would go down
the stairs and
and then she became the greatest skier
now
the story's because life has gotten
harrowing
the stories are so horrible now that
you're not you
you're just worried about the people
that are in the olympics it's like too
much of a pressure cooker
bring up that article i told you about
this this article
listen to this by the way this is listen
to this
this is the title of the cnn article
depression drove her close to suicide
now olympian raven saunders wants to
quote
destigmatize mental health um and
and good for her but the idea that
she was close to suicide and then she
discovered the shot put
is troubling
since returning from the 2016 rio
olympics her mental health had spiraled
sitting at the wheel of her car her mind
was now drawn to a dark place
from which there seemed to be no return
as she circled past a drop-off along the
mississippi highway
the urge to veer off the road towards
the towering trees
below was almost overwhelming this is
nice huh
this will be a nice montage they do
just have her sitting in her car they'll
recreate it they're like
can you take us through the route where
you thought about driving off the
highway
we want to film it we want to have like
a little compilation before you go up
and and lose
it was like no one really understood the
pain and the challenges i was going
through saunders who placed fifth in the
shot put
this is what i mean if they if if they
go
and it doesn't happen it's curtains
it got worse and worse and worse and
worse till it all boiled over
i remember in the morning just going
through the motions kind of being in a
daze
having things to do but not really
having any motivation
or any care to really get anything done
then hopping in my car and driving and
looking at that spot
a few months before saunders had
considered how the chances of survival
would be slim
if someone was to drive off the edge of
the same drop off she now circled past
however it was an impromptu text to a
former therapist really a last-ditch
effort
that saved her life she soon received a
response
was it better help providing her with
the re
assurance and courage to go home and get
the help she
needed today she's
preparing for the olympic trials in june
with the prospect of her
second olympics looming she wants to
quote destigmatize mental health
and help others who like her can get
caught up in cycles
of depression and anxiety so these are
the
types of stories you're going to hear
at the tokyo olympics i mean if you
think i mean there's not going to be any
more
cute like you know
stories where it was like you know this
athlete
you know we always knew they were
special it's gonna be like
i wanted to hang myself
and then i decided that my only hope
was [ __ ] synchronize swimming
i had an eating disorder for many years
where i would vomit up everything that i
ate
but then i realized that that positioned
me perfectly
to be a synchronized swimmer and and i
like it because only my legs
show and the rest of my body's in the
water because i still can't look at
myself
without wanting to purge but i can look
at my feet
and those are the only things that come
out of the water i keep them perfectly
pointed
i mean get ready for the tragedy
like you have never i mean
it's going to be and it used to be like
they were athletes
and it was like you know great athletes
that had like worked their entire lives
at being athletes now it's just going to
be people
who you you're worried about and you
don't think they should
you actually go we don't think you
should go we don't think you should do
this
like after i read that i go i don't know
if you should do this
this might what happens if you lose
again
what happens if she comes in and this
time she comes in seventh
it's back to the car isn't it
that's a problem she's gonna be driving
on that same
[ __ ] stretch of highway
it's gonna be sad and now with kovid
i mean there's gonna be like some
memorial in japan
to cove which people are still dying of
covert by the way yeah osaka is getting
yeah they're getting ravaged so what
they're gonna do is like you know like
if they're just gonna like they're just
gonna release like
you know those lanterns into the air and
one represents everybody
who is still in a hospital bed
it's gonna be it's gonna be very strange
olympics
i think we don't need it we can skip it
who believes no one believes that
they're gonna be in the olympics by the
way
like no one gets like very few people
get into the olympics
nobody like my mother was a swim coach
and i think a few of those people got to
the olympic trials it's
very very tough to get into the actual
olympics it doesn't
motivate anybody it might
you know but i just don't think it
it matters anymore it doesn't really
matter anymore and i don't i don't
remember the last time anyone i know
said did you see the olympics i don't
care i don't root for america i don't
care who wins
i don't really care i mean that's the
other thing does anyone give a [ __ ]
if your country beats another country
no one really cares anymore
we've gotten soft here we're probably
gonna lose and aren't these people all
junked up anyway aren't these a bunch of
drug addicts
i mean they have to they have to test
them like nine times
to make sure they're not like skin
popping
steroids in the locker room right before
they get in the pool
aren't these little junkies anyway i
mean we've just created a race of
junkies to perform these people some of
them have natural talent but
but everybody's doping
that's what the olympics is it's a bunch
of it's
it's like a bunch of lab rats doping
and i don't i don't get inspired by it
is my point
i'm uninspired by the olympics i don't
need it
and i don't know why you need it
but it's it's a it's an antiquated idea
i understand that people think it's
important but it's not
just leave it alone that's my
take on it i don't need to see a bunch
of drug addicts
run around and do hurdles i can skip
that and i think you should too
and i don't need all the stories about
she was raised by a single mother in the
bayou
you know and now she does
hurdles good
good moving on like i just don't
i don't need that it's going to be
and here's the other thing about
destigmatizing mental health you know
i'm let me say this at the risk of
offending anyone
can we de-stigmatize people who aren't
mentally ill
because i believe they are getting a lot
of pushback right now
in society the people who are not insane
i feel like are having a much tougher
time of it
mentally ill people
and not real mental illness like my
mother has like schizophrenia
but i mean mentally ill seems to
kind of be a little bit of a benefit in
certain industries
certainly the one i'm in can we perhaps
destigmatize people who
don't want to kill themselves is that
okay
is it okay that someone doesn't want to
kill themself
anymore can we destigmatize
that experience in life people who
don't want to take their car and drive
it off a road
do you think they have anything
interesting to add
everything now is about destigmatizing
mental health which i don't even know
what that means how about
funding it fun give give it funding
and help people that are insane i don't
know what destigmatizing mental health
means
and they're rarely talking about like
schizophrenia or multiple personality
disorder
it's always anxiety and depression it's
never
any of the serious real bipolar
it's always anxiety and depression which
can be real and can be serious
but also there's a lot of people that
are diagnosing themselves off of
instagram
and they really have no idea what they
have uh
they're fetishizing mental illness it's
becoming their identity
and uh they're leaning into it and this
is i am a person that understands this
because i have a mother who's seriously
mentally ill
like real mentally ill like not like she
doesn't have a twitter
they're not doing a profile her and uh
in rolling stone chris gathered
like she's actually mentally ill it's
not like a way to just
put a bunch of young kids in a room and
make money on them
just she's got an actual problem so
that's my concern only my concern is
that
but no it'll be fun get me some uh get
me some
uh inspirational olympic style music
okay
i wanna i wanna read this again with
some inspirational
olympic i just love on youtube tim
dillon discusses birds
oh from that that was a good idea i
don't even remember sex traffickers when
the bird was screaming outside
yes um olympic sport music free no
copyright
there was not a day that went by that
she didn't feel like taking her car
and driving it off the road she imagined
the sweet release of being plunged into
sub-zero freezing water
she had read she would only survive for
60 seconds and that was okay with her
as she could feel the water literally
choking her
her body all of her extremities losing
feeling as she slipped into the darkness
which she called home the final comfort
her
final resting place as she thought about
taking that
sweet barrel of a gun and putting it
right in her mouth
blowing her brains out of the back of
her head not one day went by
when she didn't think of lighting her
house on fire and
locking herself in the sweet smell of
her burned flesh
signifying that her earthly race had
been run
but then she discovered
pole vaulting and that changed her life
his mother and father raped him
constantly
they would they would they would sell
him to other pedophiles in the community
when he was a young boy he learned
a deep sense of shame after killing both
of his parents and then being
and then being sentenced to a juvenile
hall for only three years
because of the heinous nature of their
crimes against him
he finally started running ironically
something he should have done years
before
he ran and ran he jumped over hurdle
he finally found his sister his
long-lost sister later in life
and she raped him and that gave him the
strength
to pursue his dreams of running and
jumping over hurdles and now he is here
to compete in the tokyo coveted games
this is a very inspiring story
this young girl for many many years
was a nazi
raised in a small quiet suburban town in
georgia
she discovered the alt-right at a young
age she started live streaming
started asking questions about jewish
people and the shapes of other people's
skulls
for many years she became a [ __ ] poster
she fought against misogyny in the
alt-right online community
for many years establishing herself
as one of the preeminent [ __ ] poster
trolls
in the neo-nazi gaming community
then she left all that behind
to swim at the tokyo games
no longer a nazi though not really
comfortable with
everyone different races we did observe
that she was a little weird
but she's here now leaving all that
behind
to be an olympian what she was destined
to be
we are investigating an incident where
there was a swastika in the pool locker
room
we're not accusing her but we're not
we're not exactly
exempting her either but that's what
you're gonna get
at the olympics this year it's just
gonna be a horror
beyond human comprehension and you're
just gonna have to sit there and go
oh good who's competing now it's the
ex-nazi versus the person whose parents
repeatedly raped them
tough call we don't know
have you ever browsed an incognito mode
well think about this incognito like the
chrome browser is a google product and
google has made its fortune by tracking
your movements online
there's even a 5 billion class action
lawsuit against a company in california
where it's accused of secretly
collecting user data
google's defense incognito mode does not
mean invisible
so do you actually make yourself as
invisible as possible online if you
really want to you got to go to
expressvpn
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that allows you to
browse the web without companies
tracking you and selling your data
expressvpn is essential
if you want to uh see all kinds of
different content from other parts of
the world you can set your location in
the uk
and you can watch uk netflix so if you
really want to go incognito and protect
your privacy secure yourself with the
number one rated vpn
that's expressvpn.com tim dillon we have
it ben uses it we love it
uh whenever we're talking to a
journalist like abby martin or whitney
webb this is what we use
that and signal and uh we really love it
expressvpn.com
tim dillon and you get a deal you get an
extra three months for free
is that not crazy 90 days free
expressvpn.com tim dillon thank you for
supporting the show
magic spoon babies zero grams of sugar
13 14 grams of protein four net grams of
carbs in each serving
only 140 calories are serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb
gmo free build your own box available
flavors you can build our cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry cinnamon
magic spoon is great i eat it it's tasty
benny eats it everyone we know
eats it go to magicspoon.com tim dillon
to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try today if you have kids get them
started on magic spoon don't let them
eat that sugary [ __ ] from the grocery
store
they're gonna grow up to be drug addicts
and murder you but if you
allow them to eat magic spoon they feel
like it's fruity because it is and it's
good
and it's tasty but there's no real sugar
in it they use high quality sweeteners
like
monk fruit magic spoon is so confident
their product is back with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked
but nobody wants a refund they all want
more cereal
so remember sorry
sorry all right remember get your next
delicious bowl of
guilt-free sorry at magicspoon.com user
code tim dylan to save five dollars off
your sorrow
thank you magic spoon but god love
everybody
friends did a reunion which was uh
completely unnecessary
but friends was the biggest show when we
were growing when i was growing up i
forget you're younger than me
look at that hoodie everybody are you
nuts not getting that
fakebiz.net can you move the
there it is sit down
when i was growing up i was into frasier
because it was a smarter show and it was
better written
but then you had your seinfeld people
uh you had your frasier people you had
friends people
i would occasionally watch friends but i
never
cared about it french is a very
interesting time capsule of new york
city because
you know they lived in these big
apartments it wasn't even realistic
during the time but it was
more realistic than it would be now or
like you have this well maybe not now
rent is dropped but you know you had
these massive apartments where people
lived there and it was like somebody was
an actor
somebody worked at a coffee house it was
like how's this happening and they never
met a black person
well they they had there were a few
black guest stars but it was it was
that's
the they get uh flack
for the lack of diversity um
but then they had a reunion which i
didn't watch but um
people were saying that the reunion
disappointed them because
i mean this this is where people are
people are so miserable right now
that if there's any like outpouring of
joy people go wait a minute
why isn't this being tempered with a
little bit of
misery why aren't people being made
being made to feel uncomfortable
why is everyone happy that's really what
a lot of this comes down to is people
are just
completely disgusted with the idea that
other people
might be happy for a period of time
without introducing
uh something horrific and
people were upset that uh the cast of
friends was not
castigated more for their
problematic moments which by the way
none of them are really problematic like
when you look at
the things that they're upset with
friends with the show
for example in this article which is
should we forgive friends for feeling a
little offensive
um if you go down here
they said that they said that
chandler was homophobic because they
would have these gay panics where
uh basically you know
uh chandler and jo like they would be
like
um you know do i look gay or do i seem
gay or whatever which is by the way
that's not homophobic for straight guys
to
think right i mean i i i don't think
that's
inherently homophobic for a straight guy
to go do i seem gay right now
because if the goal is to hook up with
women then maybe seeming gay isn't
the greatest idea i mean
now no one seems gay or straight people
are genderless drones but
i mean i don't think it's inherently
homophobic for somebody to go do i look
gay and maybe they want to look
i mean maybe you know gay can be a
compliment many in many
uh ways the way people look not not the
way i dress but
gay people are usually very in shape and
fashionable but
i the idea that he that he goes hey
maybe i look gay that it's homophobic
also friends was insanely progressive
like you know
ross with the two lesbians i forget
or his ex-wife or whatever chandler's
dad
was a drag queen and one of the jokes
they're upset about is when chandler
um chandler says his dad opens the door
in like full drag and chandler
chandler goes hi dad and the joke is
like
great this is my dad so here they go
today it is a bit
jarring to see chandler greet turner his
father
in full makeup in a dress with a
sardanic hi
dad followed by a laugh track
why i don't understand
if your dad is in full drag it is at the
very least in most cases
not what you expected can we say that
and when he answers the door he goes hi
dad like great like this is dad
he's a whole joy yeah i mean the joke
there is that listen no one is supposed
to be like
people are always gonna have to find
reasons that they're a little
embarrassed of their parents
this is the reality of of growing up
your parents get older
uh you realize that they're fallible
human beings there's always a reason
you're a little offended by your parents
it doesn't mean it's the right reason or
a good reason right
i talk about my mother investing in
beanie babies um i think the joke is
like hi
dad like this is dad you know i don't
think it's i hate my dad
he loved his dad and he and it even says
the article but chandler's acceptance of
his dad becomes a growth experience
and the show deals more with the breakup
of his parents marriage than his
father's sexuality
um
okay here's something that people at
glad did well they go
ray bradford director of entertainment
media for glad said that even today the
portrayal wasn't
what we hate seeing on tv by a mile so
again
they're looking for reasons to be upset
but
even glad which is crazy said that this
is okay
really it's not offensive um
at all and then there were i didn't i
didn't care that much about friends
um but it was this cult show and i when
i was a tour guide in new york city i
realized
how many people around the world loved
it like people from the uk were obsessed
with it
um problematic plot lines
the one with all the fat shaming well
you know it's interesting i watched the
pilot of beverly hills 90210
i was just curious as to what was going
on i watched the pilot of beverly hills
9-2-l
the pilot jenny garth uh you know
brenda played by shannon doherty hot
chick
jenny garth hot chick brenda moves to
beverly hills from minnesota with jason
priestley her brother
and it's her first day in the new school
and of course it's beverly west beverly
high and everybody's rich
and there's a scene in the pilot
where um and i don't know if you could
play this right
we can't play something like that you
can't play that yeah yeah well a fat
girl walks into
um bio or
biology or chemistry where you know
where you have a lab
partner and you both sit at a table in
high school
and the looks that the fat girl got in
the in the room everybody was like
like i mean visually repulsed at the
idea of
so when the fat girl walks by them they
all move their books
so that she can't sit there because she
thinks somebody else is there
and jenny garth the blonde they get to
her and the fat girl goes hey is there
anyone sitting here jenny garc
yeah yeah there are and she goes who
because the fat girls had it now she
goes who's sitting here
and jenny garth as soon as shannon darty
walks in jenny garth goes
that girl and then shannon dardy comes
and sits down
and then they have a scene only a few
minutes later where
uh brenda goes yeah
minnesota is really fun because you can
eat all winter and hide it under a
sweater
and jenny garth goes yeah here
everybody's always having a pool party
so you can't really pig out that much
so i don't know that that was healthy by
the way i don't know that
that extreme was needed because it was
it was
essentially the promotion of bulimia on
that show
but we've now gone so the other way
where
it's it's also completely ridiculous as
i've covered in previous episodes with
the fat activist movement
and now what is i don't really remember
this storyline on friends is this the
one where phoebe's in a fat suit
i believe so yeah or monica's in a fat
suit
the fat suit that courtney cox is
wearing is monica is also portrayed as
being insanely possessive of her food as
though an overweight person was eat
constantly and that's funny
spoiler alert it is possible to be
overweight and actually eat well in
exercise regularly well that is true
but that's a true small percentage of
people
we also see fat mon i mean fat monaco is
kind of funny yeah it was funny
so the problem is that fat monica is
portrayed as eating
so there's this idea that we need to
divorce fat from eating
which i don't know is scientifically
true
the idea that we need to get rid of the
link between
fat and eating food
they seem somewhat inextricably linked
it's very odd to me that we have that
situation here but the friends reunion
um if you loved friends
go check it out who got fat uh chandler
chandler yeah chandler got he got big
good for him he got big
huh and there's nothing wrong with that
i'm a fat activist but let's take a look
at him
oh he doesn't look that big
i think people were saying his speech is
a little slurred i don't know i didn't
watch it so
he doesn't look bad was it matt leblanc
was it joey
jennifer aniston looks exactly how she
looks
everybody else looks a little haggard
but that jennifer addison looks great
well good for them maybe they can
compete in the olympics
every uh every everybody
now is obviously bitcoin has crashed we
have the convention coming up it has
lost half of its value
um roughly half of its value where is it
right now about 35 000.
great and we all know that we've been
on this uh we've been riding this
economic
um you know train
here at high speed for well over a
decade i mean
this is one of the biggest bull markets
in history for the longest amounts of
time
a lot of people said that it speculated
it should have ended pre-coveted
but kovid uh just allowed the government
to print money and artificially
subsidize everybody's lives
uh their new homes their you know cheap
interest rates
you know put money into the economy
stimulus blah blah blah
and then eventually this is all coming
to an end
every financial show now literally
introduces every guest like this you're
like
uh ladies and gentlemen our next guest
says that the entire world
the entire world economy will be
destroyed within 72 hours
give it up for peter schiff and then
peter schiff comes out and he's like
you know literally and i like peter
shippies this libertarian who lives in
puerto rico
who gets hard every time the economy's
about to tank
every time there's about to be like a
serious day peter shifts on every show
talking about stagflation he loves it he
just start he gets
we want him on here let's get him
somebody email peter schiff
um we want him on here uh he does not
like bitcoin
he's a big gold guy he goes [ __ ] bitcoin
it'll never be gold i wanted to bring
him
to the bitcoin convention and have him
just screaming at the people and have
them booing him being like [ __ ] you
and he's like it'll never be gold and
they're like boo
but that's every financial story right
now is that it's gonna end and nobody
really knows when it's gonna end
that's what keeps people up at night
they go
when is this gonna and how bad is it
gonna be when it falls apart
i mean if you get some of these um
articles up
i mean literally the youtube thumbnails
are like i think peter schiff has one
where it goes people will lose
everything
um i'll just type that in you know
you know dent uh i forget his first name
yeah the crash is gonna come sooner than
you think
a new crisis is coming i mean
this is a planned economic collapse
please save yourself
it's gonna crash sooner than you think
i mean he's gonna start selling merch
soon that just says crash
the final financial crisis yeah the
final financial crisis
i mean it's just please save yourself
prepare
the worst crisis of your lifetime i mean
he's he's his brand is like
because the thing about these guys and
listen he's gonna be right eventually
like one day it is gonna happen
but until it happens you gotta keep
saying it's gonna happen like there's a
great quote where it's like peter schiff
has predicted nine out of the last two
recessions
like he just doesn't stop but that's the
libertarian like austrian economist
gold standard guys and i get it but
they're always like
it's coming and it's gonna be bad
and when it comes whoa
stock market's going to go to zero like
there goes some of these guys
some of these they just they they're
literally it's just like
stock market is going to go to your so
if you want to learn how to save
yourself
sign up for the thing that i am selling
now you might think to yourself hey if
the stock market goes to zero
and we go back to a barter economy
nothing in your newsletter is really
gonna help me you might have that
thought
you might have the thought that like i
don't know last summer
people couldn't work for a while uh the
cops did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and there was a month of riots when we
still had food
and some of us still had money so you'd
imagine at stock market
zero with nothing going on
your newsletter isn't really going to
make it all okay
you'd imagine it would get pretty bad
pretty quickly you know
uh it would be like i am legend
overnight but if you want to know what
to happens in that situation
if you want to know how to protect
yourself and your assets sign up for my
newsletter
are you typing your newsletter from when
they
stormed the house and and he lives in
puerto rico a lot of these guys the paul
brothers a lot of them are getting sick
of taxes
and they go to puerto rico and they get
four percent
tax should we call the new york times
reporter
and tell him that i changed my mind and
i want to talk
given my number of mine's hooked up i'll
call because we shouldn't call him from
yours right
why not
let's see if let's see if let's see if
we could call him because
uh a new york times reporter reached out
to like they're clearly reading some
writing some hit piece on rogan and
they're like do you have any comment and
i was like hey respectfully [ __ ] off
this is his uh
this is his email hey tim this is matt
blah blah from the new york times
by the way the uh the the the header to
the email like the subject line was like
hey new york times just like hey nyt
it's like what hope you're doing well i
hope you don't mind
blank pass along your email i first met
him years ago for a story about stephen
miller the trump guy who happened to be
his classmate
i'm working on a rogan profile which of
course we know means hit piece
and have been making the rounds with
assorted friends comics podcast
it'll be very interesting to see who
talked
i was hoping you might be up for a chat
too mostly trying to get a feel for joe
as a host of what it's like to be on the
show
etc i'm at blank uh if you got a few
this week or next i appreciate anyhow
should i call him and tell him
that i i i want to report that rogan
raped me
take call his number now can we call his
number
we're going to call him and we're going
to say listen i apologize
for i outed it on social media because i
want people to know he is working on
hippies
and i want dummies see some of these
reporters are good they make it sound
like it's an approved piece
but what it really is is a hip piece so
they call people that know you and they
go
hey so we're working on this big thing
and right with whoever with tim with
your
and then they then people get lulled
into all right i'm gonna call him
he knows ben avery's name
all right hang on maybe he'll call back
does anyone answer on the sixth ring
no should i shoot him a text
um no let him call back
if he calls back which he might not but
of course i said hey
[ __ ] off because you know i know how
people twist words and everything
he's like i wanted to get a feel for joe
as a host i'm like watch the show
hey right matt right do some work
but what they want to do is they want to
convince people that this is like an
approved thing
and that uh you know it's oh it's
positive
it's positive and we are just
you know we just want to share the love
that we all have for joe at the new york
times
we just love him and we want to share
the love we have for him so if you could
participate
and there's a lot of people who will be
duped into giving quotes
but i know how to deal with the press i
said matt respectfully [ __ ] off
because i know i only will deal with the
uk press by the way because i'm
trying to sell tickets over there and
build more of a
career there and i and i know they're
trashy monsters and
i expect that that's okay and i don't
care if it's me
i don't give a [ __ ] but i'm never going
to give a quote about somebody else
that's going to be
taken out of context or used in a piece
that seeks to hurt that person
especially if it's something i like
but even if it's somebody i hate i would
not have participated in that
if they called me and said hey do you
know this uh hey we're doing a piece on
and i don't hate
these people but like we're doing a
piece on chelsea peretti or doing a
piece on whoever
i would go hey respectfully [ __ ] off
that would be my answer no matter what
new york times we're doing a piece on
this [ __ ] off every
all answers are [ __ ] off to the press
unless it's a the uk press and it's a
and it's about
me or you know whatever upcoming shows
that i have or something like that i
don't have time the world economy has
about a week left
as peter schiff says get out now i love
just the youtube thumbnails are perfect
get out now
most people will lose everything that
was another one it goes most people you
know
will lose everything
and by the way i'm not even saying that
he's wrong there needs to be a
correction
100 it's just a very fun brand
to have and i get it like he's the town
crier
it's like you know he's like the poor
reviewer going through like the british
are coming the british you know
get out now everyone you know will be
dead
we're gonna go back to a barter economy
where we just trade gold bars back
and forth yeah that'll work
and if you want to know what happens
when the stock market goes to zero
and uh the supply chains all fall
and no one has food energy money when
that happens
sign up for my newsletter if you want an
idea
i mean i mean what is the newsletter
what's the first week of that newsletter
there's just utter chaos in the street
in the first week is
so i hate to say it but i told you so
kathy wood blames elon musk
esg investors for recent crypto crash
speaking at coindesk conference
kathy we've tried to get her on the show
tried to get her as a guest to the
bitcoin conference
but she's like part of this interesting
group of christian investors
oh she's christian yeah really she's
like she's like uh
like part of this weird like culti group
of like christian investor group
like you know how like in the military
they have the knights of malta
which is like this you know kind of
weird like you know christian
group like fundamentalist uh she's part
of like some christian investor group
you know so i think she might find our
show
vulgar or crass
that's what she might i don't know could
be
but uh speaking thursday coindesk
consensus 2021 conference woods said
a lot of institutional buying went on
pause
and that it was precipitated by the esg
movement and this notion
which was exacerbated by elon musk that
there are some real environmental
problems with the mining of bitcoin
recent reports have found the energy
usage behind crypto mining is comparable
to that of some medium-sized countries
much of it coal powered
crypto bulls have challenged those
findings
she was talking the other day about you
know alternative energy sources being
used to mine bitcoin
what does esg stand for environmental
movement it's like long-term people
where they're like people communities
people communities and the environment
otherwise known as environmental social
and governance esg it's a growing
investment methodology for companies
who want to be seen as focused on the
long-term
forward-thinking leaders in their
industry corporately responsible better
man
you know what's funny about all this
stuff is that you know lockheed martin
is now doing like
woke anti-racism training the defense
contractor
lockheed martin is now like putting a
bunch of white guys in a room and having
them talk about their privilege
that's great it's phenomenal so it's
we're we're beyond self parody anymore
you can't even make fun of it you can't
do life is the sketch
nothing to be made fun of here coming up
on the show is abby
martin are uh uh what are she's a real
journalist she's a staunch defender of
israel
her new documentary missiles they're fun
for everyone
uh is out that is of course a joke uh
abby uh has a documentary called gaza
fights for freedom
um abby martin is an investigative
journalist
who spends a lot of her time overseas uh
on-site reporting um
from gaza from places like venezuela
she joins us on the show today to break
down
what she sees as uh the problem
over there in the middle east
i'm getting a little sick of it by the
way but abby's gonna break it down for
us but i'm all about
quarantine's over it's time to have fun
it's time to have fun that's what it's
time to do
but i'm very interested to hear what she
has to say
um and then of course we would have
loved to put her and barry weiss in
tanks like like glass boxes
and have them uh debate each other
interesting and we are still booked on
barry's show
when is that june 9th
i'll be in florida but oh yeah you will
you'll just do it over the phone it was
supposed to be
through zoom oh great easy
over the phone hi barry
why not so without further ado everybody
the one
the only abby martin better help there's
a lot of people you're coming out of the
quarantine you're going to see a lot of
people you're going to be anxious and
depressed you know there's people out
there you don't want to see
but you have to you got to deal with
your own mental health we're back baby
go to betterhelp.com help they've got
online professional counselors
and it's all done securely you can start
communicating in under 48 hours they've
got a broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available in
many areas
many of my friends have used betterhelp
and they love it the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log in your account anytime and send a
message
to your accounts you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a
weekly video or phone sessions better
atlp is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free
to change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
better help want you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
read their testimonials
better help you go to betterhlp.com
tim d that's better hlp.comd that's
better help and join over the 1 million
people
who have taken charge over their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp they're recruiting additional
counselors
in all 50 states this podcast is
sponsored by better help and tim dylan
show listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d what a deal
10 off their first month betterhelp.com
tim d
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost
i'll tell you right now it's fun you
need a hard dick it's going to be a
great summer of [ __ ]
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped directly to
your door in a discrete package
with bluetooth men everywhere excited to
see the postman because when your
package has arrived your package
has arrived they always say that first
impressions are important what about
lasting impressions it's time to get off
the couch and go back to work
if your tool needs an upgrade head to
bluetooth.com guys there's nothing
sexier the confidence that bluetooth can
help you give you the confidence when it
counts
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout that's
pay 5
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
td to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
this podcast is brought to you by
another podcast show i'm not being
ambiguous when i say that that's the
name of the podcast i'm recommending
another podcast show
you already know dylan rand patrick
hickey the producer of the king of the
stinging this past week and nick davis
when i raved about their hit show
another below deck podcast well they're
back
like roaches who refuse to die they're
back to ride the coattails of my success
for the duration of two more ad reads
after a dogecoin-esque investment to the
tim dillon in late 2019
this time of the more general show
unconstrained by the shackles of reality
tv recaps
covering trending topics of our time
like native american shoe salesmen
illuminati recruiters living in rural
jamaica
and the news brought to you by blue chew
call to action
bit shoot and the news brought to you by
bit shoot so if you'd like to continue
to support fake business head over to
apple podcast and leave a review for
another podcast show
say that tim dillon sent you and leave a
youtube comment on their latest episode
saying that tim dillon sent you one
thing i will say about these guys is
they keep
doing it they will not stop you have to
respect that
they've gone through like 90 versions of
this show and the 91st one's gonna hit
so go support them leave a comment leave
a review
i mean god only knows what they'd be
doing if they weren't podcasting
it would probably be something horrible
so the fact that they have this thing
that they do once or twice a week
that just keeps them going is important
to them
i mean these people would be shooting
you in the street when you were out with
your children
if they didn't have this type of thing
to do so god love them
god bless them go to another podcast
show
go to uh their youtube leave a comment
leave a review
give it a shot give it a listen
see what the deal is and if not they'll
be back with something else
because i do respect this another
podcast show
go leave a comment leave a review thank
you
abby looked phenomenal
abby looks so good i look like [ __ ]
how [ __ ] how embarrassing is this
i mean she's are we recording she spends
all her time in like war-torn countries
she looks great
i'm in the suburbs with no problems and
i look like i've been
in a war-torn country most people
listening to this show know abby martin
if you don't you should
when i say there's seven or eight
journalists left in america this is one
of them
she has a documentary out called gaza
fights for freedom
where can they watch that and where can
they support what you do that's first
off
thanks tom uh tim sorry thanks mom uh
gossip fights for freedom.com
you can check out because it's being
throttled on youtube uh youtube is now
making it impossible to actually
find it if you search for it so you have
to go to our page on empire
files uh and actually watch it there so
you can't share it from the page
you can't search for it uh they're
making it pretty hard to find
now this i know a little bit about the
conflict in the middle east you know a
lot more about it uh it seems clearly
like an unsustainable situation
um what don't people get because i think
people that are in america
that are are not really following they
only started to pay attention recently
they it's just basically like hey it's
two groups of people that don't like
each other that's kind of the simplistic
explanation that we all like we're all
just like hey they don't like each other
but it's actually uh much deeper than
that
clearly but but this idea that i never
knew that there were two million people
kind of living in this
prison that they could not leave and
could you just
go into that yeah yeah so
the media tells us that it's basically
two sides of the same
fight you know two different states just
warring over
religion and this ancient conflict that
will never be solved and it's way too
complicated for you to actually know
what's going on
it's actually really kind of easy to
understand
it's subtler colonialism we're talking
about a state that was founded on top of
another people
and every single day they continue to
take more of these people's
land and ethnically cleanse them off the
land so
there's two situations here there's a
brutal military occupation in the west
bank
uh that every day you know just making
palestinians lives just
horrible and humiliating with
checkpoints
and blockades and this is like akin to
the height of the us military occupation
in iraq i mean this is not like an
abstract thing like oh there's a base
and soldiers milling around no this is
like
soldiers are [ __ ] with you every
single day every second of the day
making your life insanely hard to live
you can't protest you can't hand out
political literature you can't raise a
palestinian flag you can't do [ __ ]
and these extremist settlers who are
taking over and colonizing the land
are harassing you and they are state
sanctioned and they are protected by the
israeli government and they can have
guns
and they're financed by the us
government right aren't we kind of
financing everything that's going on
there
now that video of the guy being like if
i don't take her house someone else will
that right that dude is actually being
funded to squat
in a palestinian home he is being
directly financed by ngos in the united
states and the israeli government
to do this um but then you have gaza
gaza is basically surprise house for
refugees
that were ethnically cleansed during the
foundation of israel
and they also continue to be sent there
as like criminals quote unquote
criminals the israeli government will
just like designate someone for their
punishment
you are now going to live in gaza for
the rest of your days
and these people cannot leave without
permits or authorization by the israeli
military
and the egyptian military is just as
hostile and they collaborate with the
israeli military
there's no basic human mobility you
can't get medical attention if you need
it um
um you there's no clean water like 97
of all the water is just non you know
it's like unpotable water
it's dirty and this is like the main
source of disease in gaza is
water that's between electricity two to
three hours a day it is it is hell
i also watched your documentary and they
said there's there's you can't get
medical supplies in
like yeah right yeah and right now
after what's happened they're not
letting fuel so you can't feel the
generators they're not allowing
construction materials to rebuild
it's basically just continuous torture
and punishment for what hamas hamas
does for 2 million people who live there
50 of which are children
so just keep that in mind every time you
know every couple of years israel just
bombs the [ __ ] out of gaza that's a war
on kids who are just innocent in a
situation
what is the justification for the
continually
bulldozing the settlements and taking
the land like i think
that seems to be a a major
problem where you're it's it's an
expansion it's it's not only a
you know like you said a you know
colonial state but it's expanding it's
like constantly expanding
what do you think the ultimate goal is
is it just to get rid of all of the
palestinians
yeah it's to it's to completely kick out
all the palestinians from the land and
take
all of the land and this is why you have
israeli officials and the government
openly saying no there will be no
palestinian state we are planning to
annex the entire territory
so you have this facade propped up by
u.s politicians being like yeah like
we believe in the two-state solution
while israeli government officials have
not entertained
the quote-unquote two-state solution for
decades this is this is a joke
right when it comes to israel society
this is an open conquest
of ethnic cleansing and the
justification
is that you know jews from all over the
world can
immediately you know if you have the
heritage of judaism in your ancestry you
have the ordained right based on
biblical ancient texts that you can go
to this land
and colonize it and take it over and you
can get citizenship
which means that you are uprooting
people who actually have
real roots in the land who lived there
for generations and this is
this is what's going on every day
netanyahu seems to have taken the thing
in a radical direction i mean not that
there weren't obviously problems before
what about him specifically has
presented this
uh you know probably uh more
radical face to what was going on was it
just was it was it his party which is
the likud party i don't know if i'm
right or not
um were they just like basically like
okay
hey now we're gonna like turn it up like
now like
what was there anybody i mean for lack
of a better word
is there any moderate voices in israel
that are like we need to not
do this yeah so there
there's not a real like quote unquote
like left opposition
or like a center opposition that's
strong to really be a counterweight to
netanyahu it is really like
the right wing and then like the fascist
right wing and netanyahu
absolutely is uh you know on the fascist
uptick i mean you can look at like
you know he's been [ __ ] president
forever it's really crazy how long he's
been president and i think that when he
rose to power he kind of emboldened a
lot of society
um to basically come out of the shadows
and just embrace kind of this genocidal
mentality that netanyahu so openly
embraces as well
through all of his rhetoric when it
comes to palestinians but just to give
you a sense of like what is the
opposition in israel like even though
there's a couple token seats in the
knesset for arabs
um that is that's you know it
it doesn't really they don't really have
power in terms of like the arab
population there you have arab-israeli
citizens who are also oppressed and
treated discriminately but benny gantz
was
the opposition to netanyahu in the
previous election and he is also
an unabashed like war criminal he's very
proud to
uh do carpet bombing in gaza he was
running the idf operations during the
2014 war and
he is equally as notoriously just
horrible
about the entire situation so it really
is like
you know a trump and then an even more
like a tom cotton or something
it's like really right you know what is
the solution
um there seems to be very little chance
that we're cutting aid in a meaningful
way
you know the last person to threaten
that was george h.w bush by the way
but there doesn't seem to be any chance
that that is going to happen
uh why do you think that is why
are we so steadfastly i understand
supporting israel but we are steadfastly
behind
everything that they do that
seems to be troubling
why is that why is that so
has become such an indelible part of
being a politician in america even aoc
you know when she went to go talk i
think it was like before jewish group
she's like
she she was like i'm a little jewish and
i know that you knew that i'm a little
and you go it's like it's a weird like
box that has to be checked why can't is
it the fear of being called an
anti-semite
is it what is it that makes people just
hesitant to go
hey we're supporting something here that
is number one unsustainable but number
two uh it's a brutal
occupation that is inhumane
i think there's several layers there the
first layer is the fact that
israel has been able to construct this
alternative reality narrative that they
are
victims in this situation and then if
you question
the entity like if you question the
construct of what zionism is you want a
second holocaust of jews right and so
for
generations people have been put on the
defense to be like no no like of course
i support israel's right to exist
as this subtler colonial entity that's
ethically cleansing people but i also
like i support palestinian rights
but i think over the last 20 years
israel's continuous going on the offense
in terms of invasions in syria lebanon
the continuous bombardment of gaza where
gaza has no air like palestinians don't
have an air force army or navy right
they have like
rockets that they're reconstructing out
of mostly israeli bombs that are dropped
on them
as well as other means they don't have
the means to
to retaliate they don't have a method of
self-defense yet israel is continuing to
just
carpet bomb them over and over again and
then of course tighten the noose
of this medieval siege um that i think
is given the perception like oh wait
maybe they aren't
you know like maybe this is not what i
thought it was so that that i think is
falling apart
more and more but that narrative has
been so successful
and they've weaponized this notion of
anti-semitism to such an extreme degree
that it's really made people
terrified of questioning it there's
another
level to this which is the highly
successful lobbying campaign
which manipulates people that that
basically
does smear you as an anti-semite makes
your life
very hard in in your professional career
right to go anywhere
if you question this i mean i remember
comparing israel to
israel's methods to nazi germany because
they were actually
forcing ethiopian jews to take birth
control which is like
i mean that that's a classic um classic
method that actually you know eugenics
method and i was
i mean it's like every every bio of me
ever online is like and she said this
like right can you believe it it's like
yeah that's actually a fact
but then then you go down to like who
are you up
u.s politicians who are corporate media
journalists you know what is their
intention
they adhere to the orthodoxy of zionism
they
they go into these outlets wanting power
and access you know i don't think
they're going in there being like
we we really care about human rights and
we're really trying to like hold power
to account no a lot of these people i
was in dc for a long time i know that
it's all about access
right and it's all about having your
career
be on the ascent and so these people go
in there playing the game tim
like they know what they need to say and
even if they disagree
look at what happened to that ap
journalist like she was fired before she
did anything because she was a member of
a students for justice and palestine
group in college
meanwhile you have the [ __ ] editor of
the atlantic jeffrey goldberg who was an
idf
prison guard like that's the strain
it does seem the balance of power is a
bit skewed um
but like but like the uh you know u.s
politicians like we grow up thinking
that israel is an extension of the us
and so we have this undying allegiance
it's like our whole mentality of this
perpetual war on terrorism
we like relate to israel like their
their experience in a war on terrorism
like we have this weird sympathy and
allegiance with them
and i think they we empathize with them
to a certain extent without
understanding even though we externalize
all of our violence with our
our wars and empire you just want a
lawsuit
you just want a big lawsuit yeah yeah so
uh and and there you go this is like
this is the cancel culture cancel
culture is a serious thing and you have
governments
around the country passing laws and 35
states now have
laws that restrict your speech your
first amendment and prevent you from
talking about
israel boycotting israel and
pro-palestine solidarity issues
this is a huge issue of censorship and
it is on the forefront of the free
speech movement in the u.s and
you know the fact that u.s politicians
feel the need to bend over backwards to
cater to israel and actually subvert the
first amendment and constitution
is quite shocking and i do think it has
to do with resources like they
they know that israel is a successful
military garrison and battering ram in
the middle east and this goes back to
the
67 war where israel was basically able
to assert
dominance in the region crush all of
these arab nationalist movements and the
us was like hey we can use israel
just like we use colombia and latin
america and just like we use uganda
and africa as these kind of
you know lynch pads that we can
yeah operations from you know and
basically
weaken the surrounding states that we
want to inevitably take down
yeah i mean i i understand that
you know israel was founded i'm like
i'm like this is the massage the mossad
has got my throat
um i understand that like america was
founded on
on settler colonialism stuff like that
i'm not saying that
israel doesn't have a right to be there
because you'd have to look at every
country that was founded in a kind of
ridiculous way
and and say that they don't have a right
to exist but there does seem to be
um a real issue with the territorial
expansion
the the open-air prison is insane you
can't keep people like that it's
inhumane it's you know
and there does seem to be and obviously
the the american
right except for certain parts of it are
are insanely pro um
netanyahu pro-israel um
and then they always give examples of
like well do you know how bad it is for
gay people in gaza which is
unlike how it is in saudi arabia which
is a party apparently or or
egypt or any of our other friends um i'm
not i don't i don't i also don't think
hamas is like a high school theater
group
i'm sure that they have there's problems
there as well
now i read in an article you're in hamas
now i'm kidding but to you
[Laughter]
uh that's that's what i mean a real but
in order to be a real journalist you
kind of do have to be in a mosque
how what is your life like dude because
people go whitney webb who we've had on
the show they call her anti-semitic
do you have problems at airports do you
have problems like because you
they know of you and yeah yeah
so how how much has that impacted your
daily life and what you're able to do
well i'm banned for life from getting
into gaza and i'm probably banned from
getting into
48 so israel uh but i haven't tried to
fly into tel aviv i feel like i
you know i feel like i know what the
outcome of that's going to be but i was
called an iranian
agent by israel when i tried to
apply to get into gaza they said you
know i'm a propagandist not a journalist
but i'm also an iranian
spy and i i was pretty alarmed by that
i'm used to being called a russian agent
or a venezuelan agent i was like that
that's scary you know when you're
called that because we know the we know
what they do to journalists that don't
toe their line and i'll just give you a
quick anecdote back in 2012 when i was
covering
war crimes on a daily basis that israel
was committing on breaking the set my
old show
they shelled a journalist tower that
they then leveled just a couple of weeks
ago
the al-sharap journalist tower and an rt
cameraman's leg was blown off
and my boss wrote them a letter and he
was like why did you shell this
journalist tower knowing that there were
journalists there and they were like
a everyone is a hamas target because
there were satellites on the roof and
whatever whatever and they're like b
your network has taken a side in the
coverage
so explicit admission of war crimes as
well as basically a
threat like an ominous threat to rt and
my
show i i presume by being like you're
covering war crimes and so we can
blow you up if we want to so yes i know
i'm on the radar
we know how crazy you know the law i
don't know if anyone's seen the lobby or
if you've checked that out by al jazeera
like
they go to great lengths to spy on just
peaceful palestinian solidarity
activists to subvert
and ruin their lives um and
it's it's an extreme extreme operation
so you know you got to watch out because
uh what role do you think
like a jeffrey epstein or someone who's
uh you know i don't know who he's
working for
no idea uh could have been france
maybe zimbabwe i don't know i don't what
do i know
right and yet some would suggest
he was uh engaging in like a blackmail
operation for the mossad with
very high-level people do you give any
credence to notions like that that that
uh you know this is something that many
intelligence agencies do and
i guess the cia and the massage is very
good at it like
is that potentially why you see people
that don't really look at this with a
critical
lens oh my god i mean look at what we
know the mossad just did they took out
actual just civilian like scientists in
iran
i mean this just happened a couple
months ago actually
just did a like a breaking bad style
machine gun
operation of like automatic machine guns
that just took out this guy
and it's just like this is the kind of
[ __ ] that they're doing all the time
absolutely i think that uh you know the
cia and masada are working very closely
together doing all these co-voter
operations
the only reason we even know about that
is i think because they were very brazen
and actually wanted us to know
right irresponsible this is part of
the kind of psyop um but yeah i think
that when it comes to things like
epstein there's a lot more that we don't
know and it what really annoys me is
people have
accepted this weird alternate reality
where they're like oh the cia just
doesn't do this stuff anymore oh yeah
they used to do the you know the dirty
wars and fun
death squads and assassinations it's
like why don't you think that they would
have just gotten
better like we're in uh surveillance
capitalism where they actually
like can it's like pre-programming they
know what we're about to do
like they they have been able to
sophisticate
their operations quite a bit like why
would you just assume that they're not
doing horrific
things on a daily basis like that where
does this lead if you if you could
uh you know step back and look at
where israel and palestine are right now
does this ever come to a resolution do
you think that this
is the pressure starting to grow and
mount for israel to take a different
course
is the leader after netanyahu more
moderate or reasonable
or does this ratchet up just constantly
it ratchets it up constantly and
netanyahu i think
is emblematic of where israeli society
is at
um because when he got into power people
were able to kind of
take the masks off and say this is what
we feel
you know we they embrace netanyahu and
in fact whenever he
does things like just happened in the
gaza strip his poll numbers shoot
through the roof
you can see this reflected in polling
throughout the country 95
of israeli jewish citizens supported the
gaza war
80 to 85 support the shoot to kill
policy at the border i mean that would
be similar to like 85 percent of
americans supporting just
executing migrants like wandering around
by the border
like that i mean it's a really fascist
society and yes of course there's
opposition of course and i believe in
our defense we only have 75
of americans uh supporting executing
migrants so i think that's right
it's a country
what does a two-state solution look like
you'd have to normalize trade with
palestine right you'd have to
there'd have to be an an agreement where
palestine could trade with other
countries i mean
they would have to have the rights
they'd have to have right to go places
and
i mean that was the hope when i was
growing up in the 90s
that's all i heard was two-state
solution two-state solution
and that was the also and that was you
know that was basically arafat
and uh the plo and all of these like
secular
nationalist palestinian movements that
were supposed to be a counterweight to
the islamist rise of hamas that actually
israel
helped create and fund and wanted to win
the election so then they can just
blanket gaza's this you know hostile
entity and justify everything that they
do by
you know hamas being the government but
they helped
make that happen they helped create the
situation today so then they can just
perpetually use hamas as an excuse now
what does this do
to state versus one state i think
palestinians have shown that they are
willing to negotiate
what that is but going back to the oslo
accords that was supposed to be the
future palestinian state was
what the west bank is and that has been
atomized and taken over by settlements
completely so for me it's hard to
imagine what the state would look like
when
it there is no state to be had i mean
it's you have to go from one settlement
to the next you have to cross military
checkpoints only 17
of the west bank is actually palestinian
territory without israeli soldiers
present
the rest is is horrifically under
occupation
you would have to dissolve those
settlements and retreat
the settlement boundaries back to the
1967 borders which
is a formula of national consensus
palestinians have have
talked about that they would accept that
but again like israeli
government officials have have declared
that that is not on the table
even hamas has been willing to negotiate
those lines
so people have said well what's the
other solution a one-state solution
which means
you know stopping the occupation lifting
the siege and giving
the 5 million palestinians who have no
human rights or equality
basic democratic rights and having one
person one vote
but that would kind of fly in the face
of of what israel is i mean it's an
artificial israel is how many people
live in israel
uh oh man i want to say like seven
million i
might be way off um [ __ ] i
i might just look at that
like for example it's in in east
jerusalem there's a 70
demographic law that you have to have 70
israeli jewish citizens there versus 30
arabs
which means 9 million you were close oh
great yeah
it's an artificial majority which
necessitates like ongoing expulsion of
people who live there you know what i
mean and like yeah like i think that we
have this abstract notion like yeah the
native genocide was really bad slavery
was really bad that should happen
hundreds of years ago
but we still feel the remnants of racism
and a lot of institutions
imagine that happening like now right
that's happening
every day it seems like a two-state
solution is the best
course if israel is willing to give back
some of that land
and you know they can figure it out but
it seems
unlikely it seems unlikely without math
it seems like it's going to be tough to
do a one state
at this point with all of them that's
going to be because
that's all that's all predicated on the
the false premise that
you don't want israel to exist as a
jewish state and that
you know that's where everything falls
apart and i will say you know back to
this anti-bds legislation that they're
passing
this is super surreal because the
israeli lobby and
israeli government officials as much as
we hear this hysteria about
russian interference in our democracy
israel has been interfering in our
democracy for
years and years they are trying to push
the boundaries of what
we will accept like legislatively to
actually change the laws here like
i think that they know these anti-bds
laws are blatantly unconstitutional but
they're just throwing them out there and
seeing what sticks
you know just like they tried to
actually sue a palestinian woman here
for defamation but knew the statute of
limitations had to run out so then they
could apply
israeli law in the u.s
that was struck down as well but this
shows you like how far they're actually
pushing
because they know that they can go far
here and they know a lot of people
will just blindly pass these laws
knowing that they are
i mean it's just so flagrant and crazy
and brazen that they are trying to
undermine free speech
by saying you can't talk about this you
like you can't work
in 35 states unless you pledge to never
boycott israel that's nuts
right well it doesn't seem like anybody
wants free speech in this country maybe
you do
maybe i do maybe there's a collection of
people but
left to the right nobody really wants
free speech but they've been very
successful but congrats to you
because you won that lawsuit which i
think
maybe is a turning point there because
you can't
define what people are allowed to to
uh boycott or what they're allowed to
talk about
it's crazy you were going to give a
speech on a college campus right
yeah yeah this is supposed to be the
beacon of free speech
you know across the country and i was
supposed to give a keynote speech about
media not even palestine and i was given
a contract that says you can never
boycott the state of israel if you want
to make money
in georgia and make this honorarium so i
refused to sign i sued and
a year and a half later on the heels of
the vicious onslaught in gaza the judge
ruled
that this was unconstitutional because
what it did was basically say i need to
adhere to a certain type of political
belief
or speech which is exactly what it was
um and
and just imagine how crazy that would be
to replace the word israel with any
other entity including the us and
georgia right like you would
be beyond the realm of comprehension if
you were given a contract being like you
can never boycott russia
and then you had putin taking to twitter
which netanyahu did
after the lawsuit was filed bragging
about the fact that they have passed
these laws in the u.s being like we've
worked really hard
to pass all these laws and we're gonna
boycott whoever boycotts us it's like
now you're threatening us like how is
this real yeah
no i mean it's it's it's absurd really
it's absurd
it's absurd gaza fights for what are you
doing on memorial day are you
do you ever have fun because everything
you do is so serious me and rogan
were talking about it the other day we
said abby where he's like i brought more
knows balls mom
and do you ever just relax
and have a nice uh memorial day weekend
without having to check for all your
stuff being bugged
i do man i i love nature i love uh
having fun i like to laugh
yeah did your brother leave twitter what
i mean you gotta you gotta [ __ ]
chill out we miss your brother on
twitter i don't know what happened to
robbie on twitter we used to
call him at 3am and and to try to hunt
down people from
the 911 truth movement you're
you're all wired jazzed up jacked up and
called them talking about 9 11. i
appreciate that
yeah i mean listen that's until an
experience
two o'clock in the morning call you
about nine gaza fights for freedom
uh watch the documentary i didn't know
much about this but i watched it and i
was like this is [ __ ]
wild uh and and again and we're gonna
have all your stuff in the description
of the youtube video here which i'm sure
they'll take down
but tell everybody uh where to find you
yeah so gaza by supreme really quickly
this this shows you what happens when
palestinians peacefully resist
this was a mass march and they were
mowed down by snipers uh and it was
a very shocking war crime that has been
completely covered up
find me on twitter abby martin find uh
empire files on youtube
gazafreedom.com while it's still allowed
to be up tim thank you so much for
caring about the issue and having me
again i'm i'm i'm learning more and more
about it but that documentary is is
harrowing
so uh everybody go check that out and
and uh go read what abby writes even if
you don't agree with her
she's doing she's there you're not there
i'm not there you're she's talking to
people
i tried to join hamas he said no so
abby martin find the idf man you can go
join the idf
they don't want me either they won't say
yes to me i've had whitney webb on too
many times
all right yeah the weinsteins will stop
that
anyway abby martin thank you so much we
appreciate it
happy memorial day yeah peace out